Okay, let me take a break from the serious
stuff.
But this is so funny and we need a little
bit of levity these days.
So maybe you'll grant me a couple of minutes
for this.
Every once in a while I'll do something random
on the show just to make things up, mix things
up for myself, mix things up for people.
Uh, do a little something different with the
staff just to, to, uh, as a joke.
Once at our New York city studio, the heat
wasn't working in the entire building, so
I wore like a big winter coat and a hat during
the show.
And I don't think I ever really explained
what I was doing or why I did that.
And I've got a whole bunch of emails about
it once.
A couple of years ago I did an entire show
with my hair looking really odd to celebrate
that we reached 2000 patrons on our Patrion
page and it created quite a stir earlier this
week.
I did the show with my hair looking odd and
there really wasn't any reason for it other
than I just felt like mixing things up.
Our audience was so concerned about it that
I want to show you some of the hilarious messages
I received and I love this because a lot of
people were seem genuinely worried about me
that my disheveled hair was assigned, that
the Iran thing was really getting me down
or something like that.
Sometimes I just do things for a reaction
because I'm curious if something like this
will take over the comment sections and typically
it does.
Once during a live stream I did on YouTube
I wore a sweatshirt that had a weird shawl
color that almost looked like a bathrobe and
like 90% of the comments on the live stream
or about my shawl color.
So check out some of the comments, um, that
I uh, that I got about the hair stuff.
Warren has a plan for everything.
I wonder if she has a plan for David's hair.
100% of David's haircuts are being paid for
by no one.
Are you?
Okay.
David unshaven disheveled hair looking matter
and matter.
And this is from a guy who used to have long,
long hair.
You're not looking well mate.
Hope all is well.
Have you thought about a break?
I actually just took a break.
I'm feeling quite good.
Seriously.
Do something with the hair.
At least the fork in a light socket look is
an improvement over the usual Gumby, Gumby
slant.
Sorry to be off topic, but your hair has a
life of its own at the moment.
Soon it'll have its own zip code.
No doubt you're making a lot of balding men.
Very jealous.
Maybe the funniest.
This is from a very nice lady who watches
the show with her husband.
I posted this to my social media.
This is my favorite.
Hi David.
Lots to worry over.
But Terry and I are hoping you're okay as
your hair is more disheveled each passing
day, so we wish you well.
Thank you for your opinions.
Warm regards from down under.
I'm fine.
I appreciate the concern.
It's just a joke.
Sometimes we do things to mix things up.
Producer Pat was perplexed by my hair a couple
of days ago.
I actually, uh, I've run the idea by Pat of
one day just wearing a fake mustache, but
never mentioning it.
Like never addressing it, never explaining
how it appeared one day and was gone the next.
But now that I see how many people were worried
about just my hair, hundreds and hundreds
of comments about it, I should probably think
twice about it.
Let me know if you were worried about me on
Twitter at [inaudible],
the Pacman.
Follow me there.
We will take a quick break.
Huge, huge Friday show for you today.
I'm glad you're with us.